we had huge benefits from the Twitter  exercise we did a few months ago you  know so we use it all the time in  getting information out of the public in  dealing with the rumors so I think to be  fair the government recognized that and  there's been a lot of concerns about  social media in the current situation  but on the other hand it is a very  valuable tool of getting information out  there and it's not just about that sort  of social media we've seen people  operating on mobile phones texting those  sorts of things so it is a wider issue  and I think clearly there has to be a  balance here and it is about developing  new techniques but I think overall you'd  have to say on balance that social media  and Twitter in particular has worked to  the benefit of the Republic and the  benefit of us can now to get information  out to the public